from exclusive items to portion sizes we
want to find all the differences between
KFC in the US and Italy this is food
Wars new season Italy new host want to
introduce you to a familiar food Insider
face
Claudia let's start with the original
recipe chicken if you're buying just the
original chicken you can get a two-piece
one is huge we also have lots of bucket
options but most of them combine the
original recipe wings and tenders if you
only want the original chicken the
largest size we have is a six piece
bucket looks a bit skin the other bucket
options include a variety of chicken
such as tenders and hot wings for
example if you want to feed two people
you can get the 10piece bucket this
contains four tenders and six crispy
tenders and if you want to feed four
people you can get this big boy here
this one is a 16 piece bucket and
contains four original recipe for $10
tenders for crispy tenders and for wings
this is actually the biggest thing on
the menu then in the US KFC's chicken
comes in four portion sizes you can
start off by getting a one piece alart
then a two-piece with a combo a three
piece with a combo and a four piece with
a combo all of which come with the side
of your choice a biscuit and a drink
then for the buckets we have an8 piece
the 12
piece o
and last but not least this luscious
bucket 16 pieces of chicken dinner is
served in America you can get those in
either original or crispy that makes our
biggest bucket 166% bigger than Italy
I've actually never really had KFC
before chicken is not so popular in
Italy like espe especially Fried Chicken
served like that so I'm really curious
to try it and
see yeah nice not a lot of spices it's
just like fried chicken which is what
what we promised let's see how one
chicken drumstick weighs compared to
Italy 64 G 97 G is anyone surprised that
the chicken in the United States is
bigger than every other country we've
done this food Wars with in Italy we
also have hot wings and they come in a
five piece and in a 18 piece bucket this
one is designed for three people
18 Wings in the US is definitely for one
person not three I could have six wings
and then have a full meal so they're
advertised as hot
wings I think to an Italian palette yeah
you could say these are spicy we also
got Wings here in the US now currently
at least the KFC I went to here in
Burbank has one size of wings the eight
piece and go ahead and take the bones
out crispy he heat I can notice that
isn't overwhelming perfectly fine next
are the fries in Italy you can get three
sizes small medium and large in the US
we got two sizes of fries the individual
and the large let's weigh our biggest
size I never grow tired of that is this
the lowest we've gotten we've gone to
the same KFC every time apparently they
have fired that scooper because he or
she was being too generous in Italy KFC
offers drinks in two sizes a medium and
a large drinks in the US get two
fountain drink sizes the regular and the
large I will point out to you Claudia
and the rest of Italy that are regular
the smallest drink you can get at a KFC
is 591 ml which is much bigger than your
large but if you really want your thirst
quenched you get yourself the big
boy that is a half gallon 64 fluid
ounces or 1,000
92.7 mL of Beverage let's measure the
large one to see if that's
true supposed to be 887 let me just even
get it up to 800 wo this is just 800 the
messes that this show forces me to
make if you are incredible at balancing
and you don't want a cap I guess this is
okay if you're just going to sit at your
table
like here's everything that you can get
a k in Italy that you won't find in the
US here's everything you'll find at a
KFC in the US you won't find in Italy we
have one exclusive chicken option you
can't get in Italy that is the extra
Krispy this is probably Clos to where
you get your original recipe and then
you got the extra crispy I mean
obviously it's it's night and day volume
up on this one this is
regular and of course the extra
crispy if you're wondering yes way
better way more
flavorful we don't have extra crispy
chicken here in Italy but if you order
tenders you're going to get original and
crispy it does look much crispier it
also looks just looks much sad SW is
like literally flopping at least I can
see the chicken I can see some meat in
there this one is like completely hidden
in the butter like it could be anything
another exclusive are the KFC
nuggets you can get these in varieties
of 5 8 12 and 36 I went with the five
piece now Claudia take a good look at
this you and Italy have popcorn chicken
besides potential size differences I
really don't know what else is different
about these in Italy we don't have
nuggets but we have popcorn chicken it
we got the large but it comes also in
small and medium quietly sometime last
year KFC just took popcorn chicken off
the menu and I'm pretty bummed about
that I mean I like the Nuggets but the
popcorn chicken man it's just something
cuz they're a lot smaller and then the
chicken to skin ratio is more in favor
of the skin so you get a lot of that
savory skin in there rip popcorn chicken
you're very lucky Claudia you are very
lucky we were you guys like the guinea
pigs for this or are we the guinea pigs
for like a new recipe or
something I think I prefer a whole piece
like I think binging on like little bits
of chicken it's like so un Italian that
um I'm not sure that i' be getting used
to that snacking on little bits of fried
chicken while in a convenient tog go box
while driving a walking around is so
American and I love it I got to try this
this is what America's all about let's
move on to the chicken sandwiches in
Italy we have the Zinger this is
supposed to be Italy's version of the
spicy chicken that you guys have in the
US I don't know Joe how does that look
like similar yes Claudia your Zinger
sandwich look looks a little bit like
our spicy chicken sandwich here's ours
and we only have pickles on ours so no
lettuce and
tomato but after I took a bite you can
see there's like some red here so that's
supposed to be the spice there's like
the tiniest tiniest tiniest spice to be
honest then moving on we have this uh
tiny little thing the cranky crunchy or
cranky this one here is on the value
menu so it's more cheaper option and
then we got the colonel named after
colonal Sanders we don't really have
colonal here nothing we do but we keep
them for the Army I don't think theyve
ever opened a chicken restaurant then we
got the double Colonels does that mean
that another person joins then we have
the kentucki chicken and bacon I have to
say this is the biggest bacon that I've
seen in like Italian fast food chains
this to me feels quite quite thake and
you can also get this one in a double
and then we have the chicken grilled so
sauce sad sad lettuce hanging off Mayo
you can also get the double crispy which
is two chicken tenders in a bun here are
sandwiches you can get in the US you
can't get in Italy starting down here
the classic Chicken Little I don't know
it's just a tender in between two buns
here's what I would do I would go to KFC
I'd stand in line I'd order my meal and
get one of these and then demand they
give me this while I wait for the rest
of my food it's nothing it's nothing
it's like an appetizer and then of
course just the regular chicken sandwich
I have said on record several times that
I think KFC might have the best fast
food chicken sandwich in America there's
also apparently an ultimate barbecue
fried chicken sandwich that was new I
think it came and went as an Italian I'm
not so big on chicken burgers I think
the idea of having chicken in a burger
doesn't really resonate so well with us
it's like almost hurts my eyes there's
just too much Brown in it like I want to
see more color yeah that's absolutely
not the case here here as you can see
our chicken is deep fried and covered in
a mayoi sauce we're eating chicken all
the time in America yeah we eat a lot of
beef but we also eat a lot of chicken
and it is no way diet food here not at
all we also used to have Twisted wraps
here at KFC in Italy but sadly they're
not on the menu anymore they're still
worth mentioning though because of the
hilarious advertising uh campaign when
KFC launched them in Italy they actually
designed Italian leather handbags
supposed to hold your Twisters which is
a bit of a knockoff to like the fendy
baguette bag all right we might not have
Italian bags for our WS but we do have
KFC Crocs look how cool those look we do
have a couple wrap options you only get
them through the KFC application which
is not how I ordered anyway get the
classic one with a crispy tender there's
also a spicy one that I assume is
spicier and apparently you get two of
them for $5 which a pretty good deal but
I didn't get them here's a few hilarious
things things you can't get in Italy
over here is the famous bowl yes Claud I
know you're dying to know all about this
so I will tell you now it is nuggets
mashed potatoes gravy corn cheese
allinone convenient tub so this would be
I guess what's considered a
bites it's really heavy it's got to be
90% mashed potato it's a lot another
American exclusive is this a chicken pot
pie look at the size of this thing I
think this would just profoundly confuse
every Italian here's the thing about the
mashed potatoes and gravy you have to
get them together having them separately
seems very strange to me it is a classic
us side dish especially with things like
fried chicken apparently when Colonel
Sanders sold the business he compared
the mashed potatoes in a Manhattan store
to wallpaper paste topped with sludge
but that was back in the 70s so
hopefully they've made some improvements
I'd say that they have I mean I know
like those those mashed potatoes look so
dry I understand you want to put some
some sort of liquid on them I just not
have any of it but for once the potatoes
don't look like radioactively yellow so
that should be a good sign we happen to
have some Italian style sides here on
the menu although I have no idea who
called this Italian stuff because no
Italian to me we have cheese puff to me
this look like like fried baby bells
that's the only cheese that I can think
of that have this
shape
I think it's some kind of
mozzarella no okay yeah we have breads
just like funny funny bread it looks
very dry just but look in it and then we
have corn on the cob the US has off the
cob this is like not Italian I've never
seen an Italian person have corn the cob
in Italy we also have four salads but we
were not able to get them today those
are uh grilled chicken crispy chicken an
original chicken which we don't know how
that differs from the crispy one and a
veggie
salad right Claudia look at that look at
that mac and cheese it's American mac
and cheese I mean I don't really have
thoughts about mac and cheese because to
me that's just not Italian uh we just
sort of gave up on it and be like you
want it it's yours yeah I get it like
bright yellow but
Claudia what you can tell is how good
this
tastes other us sides you can get here
klaw Claudia was talking about corn on
the cob we got corn off the cob AKA
sweet corn I'm just thinking in terms of
the American Experience I don't really
be all like doing this at my desk KFC
for lunch and I want to eat it and get
going so another thing we have here
biscuits and I feel like you get these
with these types of meals cuz it's good
at sapping up things like good at
sapping up the gravy on their own
they're just
so I want to see if I can eat one like
without any liquid like how long it
takes me to eat a dry one ready this is
how dry these are ready timing
go I'm only halfway
through hurt
time yeah not my favorite another
exclusive you can get here in the US is
a piece of alart chicken I feel like if
you went into a KFC in Italy it was like
I just want one drumstick they'd give it
to you I don't think they'd really push
back on it but our menu specifically has
you can get an individual piece of
chicken you get a drumstick a thigh or a
breast get chicken in this hand Famous
Bowl in this hand and walk right in the
traic sauce talk let's
go in Italy we have some exclusive
sauces starting from the original I know
you guys in the US have the cave sea
sauce does this look
similar I think if I were making sauces
I would have just continued you know
triing others after this
one yeah it's like a mayoi barbecue
ketchup and then we have the Smokey
barbecue sauce and then we have the
sweet imperial sauce that's a sweet and
sour
sauce very lemony but fresh yeah it's a
nice one I like this then move on to the
too hot for you jelly
like it's not too hot for you it's just
too bad for me moving on we also have
garlic sauce I know you guys associate
Italy and Italian cuisine with garlic
please stop doing that we don't really
like it then we have a fresh pepper one
this one apparently contains
cheese tastes like no much to be honest
we also have creamy Curry finally we
couldn't get the only olive oil but we
do have olive oil and white vinegar and
olive olive oil and balsamic vinegar I
don't know if you want to consider olive
oil a sauce I have like mixed feeling
about it cuz that's definitely more
dressing are you curious to see how
chicken olive oil tastes like let's try
it olive oil and balsamic vinegar let's
see kind of brought it back to life a
little bit cuz he had cool down I should
do this more often actually it tastes
less fried for some reason cuz I always
associate olive oil with like grilled
chicken so if you want to you know trick
your mind into thinking that you're
eating grilled chicken and not fried
maybe all you have to do is pour some
olive oil on it honey mustard honey
barbecue that's good buffalo ranch if
you are on aware we have a sauce here
that usually is on wings called the
buffalo sauce it's like a vinegary hot
sauce that is a a little north of
mild and the reason that Buffalo Ranch
is a thing is because when you eat
buffalo wings and they're spicy you dip
the wings in ranch a second sauce to
cool it down so we as Americans are used
to pairing buffalo sauce on the wings
with ranch dressing so they were like
let's just put it in one CU God forbid
we have two sauces but you want to have
just regular Ranch everyone on the
internet come at me all right Ranch is
just okay it all tastes the same also we
have a hot sauce a honey sauce we have a
lot of desert options here in Italy most
of them are just ice cream we start from
a plane ice cream cone then you can get
sanday they come plain caramel flavor
Nutella strawberry and chocolate and
then we have these the cream bowls they
come with Nutella flavor caramel
strawberry and chocolate they're kind of
similar to a sunde but they have that
this crunchy bottom and apparently the
caramel one is supposed to have lots of
layers this is the caramel one but I'm
not sure we can judge the number of
layers cuz it has absolutely melted so
we got a Nutella cream bow and a caramel
one uh you know those like backpacks for
cats I think it's like the same thing
here curious about the crunchy bottom oh
yeah that is
crunchy actually reminds me a little bit
of you know the Ala the Cornetto it may
have another name in the US and they
have that crunchy bit at the bottom I
mean for us Italian Nutella is like dog
chocolate before chocolate always comes
Nutella just no questions asked it's
always been like this and before cream
as well uh the only exclusive dessert
option we have in America is this a
chocolate cake and it just occurred to
me I've actually never had this cake
let's see how we
did perfect cooked beautifully it's got
the right amount of Bounce isn't dried
out and now we taste
it exquisite you keep baking like that
you're going to win this competition I'm
I was started up as Gordon ramay every
impression I do of anyone is just kind
of that this actually pretty good yeah
they had those uh those those balls
that's those cream balls which is kind
of a weird thing to call it no I don't
want any of those I get it I like
dessert just as much as next guy but KFC
I want to load up on fried chicken I
want to load up on mac and cheese I want
to load up on mashed potatoes and want
to load up on corn if only someone could
put it all in one bowl for me dessert no
I want to eat eat fried chicken and tell
about the burst and then I'm out so the
exclusive drinks in Italy are seven up
lipon IC tea and beer found drinks you
can get in the US we do have a bunch of
exclusives I didn't get every single one
relax all right starting down here sweet
tea oh yeah their lemonade it's really
good it's addictive and our lemonade is
not carbonated it's still Mountain Dew
it's fantastic and the reason I saved
this one for last is something you get
exclusively at the KFC in the us it is
Mountain Dew sweet lightning it's so
good like you just know it's like super
sweet and super chemically but I love it
other drinks you can get at a US KFC
that we not get was star and blackberry
lemonade which is currently
unavailable which country is getting a
better deal on its KFC let's compare a
few menu items to find out looking at
the chicken sandwich combo meal which
comes with a side and a medium drink
this whole thing in Los Angeles would
cost you
$10.99 notee if you got each item
individually added up it would be
$12.76 in Italy you can also get a
similar meal that is called a Zinger
meal and that includes a sandwich a side
of choice and a drink this will cost you
€140 at the time of recording that is
equal to
$1.52 so that is 5% more expensive than
the US meal if you order these items
individually that will cost you €1
1360 and that's about $15
$6 we also took a look at KFC's most
expensive items in Italy the most
expensive item on the menu is the 16
piece bucket this one cost
$42.90 which is about
$47 51 this is supposed to feed four
people for
$11.87 per person most expensive item on
the US menu is the 16 piece chicken meal
which includes 16 pieces of chicken
original or crispy four large size eight
biscuits and it cost you
$52.99 now this is meant to feed 7 to
eight people sure and it cost roughly
$662 per person which is 44% cheaper
than Italy's per person cost Italy KFC
puts a lot of efforts in this meals and
special offers so they can be better
value for money personally in Italy
we're not really used to having meals uh
we're very accustomed to just having a
big main course
that to me still feels a bit of an
American thing but uh this is American
food so I guess we're using their
customes as well if you're operating
under the assumption that this is for
seven people it's a pretty good deal but
you and I both
know this ain't for seven
people we want to see if there are any
similarities in the nutrition of KFC for
both countries now this is our chicken
sandwich and it has
650 calories if you'll notice there's a
lot of salt and fat in this sandwich
much over half your daily recommended
intake KFC Italy doesn't disclose their
calories on their website actually I
think disclosing nutritional information
like calories and everything I find that
quite an American thing that doesn't
mean it's like good or bad it's just
like we we don't really tend to count
calories in things every food Wars we've
done all the nutrition info all the
ingredients info in the US you can get
it no problem other countries they don't
provide
it let's take a look at are some
ingredients that KFC uses here in Italy
here are all the ingredients for the
fries nine is a lot potatoes and frying
oil how about two two ingredients and a
bit bit of salt and one chemical let's
just use one you know if we have two and
here are all the ingredients of the
fries in the
US 33 ingredients that's 24 more than
the ingredients in Italy's fries that's
nuts nine ingredients for this thing and
it doesn't even molded shade I would
expect it to be like perfect there's a
lot of flavors and colorings that be
used like paprika turmeric and aneto
extract color which is funny we put that
into the fries but we're making this KFC
also uses bleached white flour which
removes all the color so it seems kind
of counterproductive like they're taking
all the color out with the bleached
flour right and they're putting all
those chemicals back in to make them
look like fries I don't know why we do
that either so let's have a look at the
ingredients for a chicken drumstick
Italy chicken uses a lot of flavor an
aners gums and stabilizers for example
ganam gum and gu gum they are used in
meat products to keep the chicken tender
during the cooking process these gums
are also used for chicken that has a
butter around it so that when it's fried
it absorbs less oil as I said before
like Italians don't really look at like
ingredients like nutritional value
things and that is why I think there is
a lot of work done beforehand for us in
order to make the food as simple as
possible so that if you do look at the
ingredients you're not so shocked by it
and here are the ingredients of the
chicken in the US surprisingly smaller
than Italy's list although the US has
not noted what oil they use for frying
like Italy has so it would probably add
a few more ingredients now KFC actually
uses pressure frying instead of deep
frying like the other chains as it
allows for faster cooking time and
always keeps the meat moisture as less
steam evaporates let's take a closer
look at a few ingredients that some of
us may not rec recognize okay first up
sodium phosphate that helps stabilize
the pH of the food to keep them together
but is also popular over the counter
medicine for bow movements so don't be
surprised if Eden KFC makes you uh rush
to the bathroom next up mono sodium
glutamate flavor enhancer commonly add
to soups and processed Meats we're
putting these names on screen right uh
this word looks like this and is
probably pronounce
dimyan
dioxane is antifoaming Agent derived
from silicone usually added to oils jams
and canned vegetables disodium
dihydrogen pyrophosphate this should be
a contest anyway okay prevents potatoes
in the fries from turning brown due to
oxidization which is natural for most
fruits and vegetables and just to add
that all these ingredients have been
approved by health professionals and
there are no safety concerns as long as
long as they're eaten in lower
quantities which in general is good
advice for eating fast food chickens in
the US are free of added hormones and
steroids however KFC does not disclose
much else about how the chicken is
prepared nor how much chicken is used
per item as of 2019 young Brands the
parent company of KFC stopped purchasing
chicken raised using antibiotics so I
guess they're heading in the right
direction KFC opened their first Outlet
in the 70s in Naples for some reason and
that that didn't work out and they
closed and then they came back to Italy
in 2014 the objective was to open 100
branches in four years they're not quite
there yet as of 2022 the stats say that
they've open 68 branches here in Italy
although it's been here since 2014 it
does still feel pretty new like Italians
are not so big on like chicken
especially grilled chicken it does still
feel like a very foreign idea KFC is so
popular in the US maybe the most popular
chicken chain Fried Chicken chain at
least I think it's like the Fried
Chicken chain to beat in the US there's
other chicken places that do chicken
sandwiches chicken burgers but as far as
like chicken on the bone I don't know
who's even competing with KFC I guess
it's Popeyes oh yeah Popeyes no I think
KFC is way more popular than than
popey's I say it's better if a KFC opens
in a new town for example in my hometown
he open last year there are huge lines
there are a lot of people that want to
try it because it's really the idea of
the American fast food chain that's
arriving so it's exciting it's different
again it's one of those things that I
think you do try it because of the hype
KFC adaptability is weird a couple years
ago it used to be a lot more stuff on
the menu and now is a lot less so their
adaptability is less about making stuff
that kind of caters to people's tastes
and more like no one's getting the wings
let's just do the Nuggets let's take all
this stuff off the menu let's pair it
down go go go for efficiency and
probably because it's cheaper to have
less ingredients so they've adapted to I
don't know um shifts in the market or
people's interest in KFC they really
don't deviate too far dish Wise from
like a fried chicken or a chicken in a
bun KFC is actually the chain that has
made the least effort to italianized the
menu I don't know actually weirdly I
think that for this it works because the
idea of eating fried chicken is so
foreign to us that I don't know how you
would how would you make that Italian
you maybe put some like fried coret
flowers with the chickens I don't know
you know for me to even think about a
similar Italian thing that weirdly I
think this may be working the way it is
so we'll see when they will reach 100
branches maybe sooner than we think it
make note of the fun Colonel Sanders
doing a cartwheel wasn't this a guy like
70 when he started Kentucky Fried
Chicken so no way he's doing if he's
doing that it's against his
will moments before the ambulance was
called